okay everyone that trailer was in sane
this trailer makes me extremely hyped
for Captain Marvel and it's clear as to
how she's going to be one of the most
powerful heroes in the MCU so far I mean
heck it looks like we're getting a Super
Saiyan in the MCU this is crazy super
amazing trailer let's get into the
breakdown okay so the first part we have
Nick Fury who was working for shield not
director fury yet just an agent for
shield remember this takes place in the
1990s so we have Nick Fury who's a young
agent for shield riding in the car with
Carol Danvers so she basically just told
Nick Fury her story who the Kree are who
the scroll are so he's repeating it back
to her trying to understand it and of
course it's setting it up for the
audience to understand who the heroes
are who the bad guys are so he starts
off by saying so scrolls are the bad
guys then it shows the old lady on the
train Carol Danvers is on the train as
well she looks at her and then carol
danvers punches her in the face and then
all of a sudden this fragile old lady
just jumps up and starts attacking her
and that's because she is a scroll so
one thing about the scroll that makes
them extremely dangerous is the fact
that they can shape-shift so this little
old lady is actually an alien a scroll
in disguise and then Nick Fury goes on
to say and you are a Kree a race of
noble warriors and then Carol Danvers
corrects him by saying hero's noble
warrior heroes and then it shows her
walking in front of Star Force this is
her team they're basically like a SEAL
Team six for the Kree they're an elite
combat group so it shows star force
walking to their ship in a grand
beautiful city on their home planet
which in the comics is called hala and
then it cuts to the Marvel Studios logo
so what it's basically doing is setting
up the kree-skrull war in the comics the
kree-skrull war was the highlight of its
era it was just a huge cosmic
interstellar battle that involves so
many characters such as The Avengers the
Fantastic Four Marvel Rick Jones Adam
warlock fan OHS just so many characters
involved and it's so awesome to see a
movie that's going to be about the Crees
girl
war okay so after we cut to the Marvel
logo we hear and see a net benning's
character so she's obviously a Kree and
she's explaining how the Kree found
Carol Danvers and how she became a Kree
because Carol Danvers is initially just
a human but her DNA becomes part Kree in
part human made you one of us
so you could live longer stronger
superior but what's really interesting
here is while a net benning's character
is explaining how they found her it
shows her after some sort of an
explosion lying on the ground and she
has green blood so it appears like she
is already a Kree in this scene right
here or she may have just became a Kree
so what happens in the comics is that
Carol Danvers is kidnapped by the
villain yan rug and the Kree Marvel goes
to safer and him and Yan rock start
fighting and a forbidden Kree machine
called the psyche magnetron explodes and
this fuses Carol Danvers his DNA with
marvel's making her part Cree and part
human so as we continue to watch the
trailer you can clearly see that Carol
Danvers is involved in some sort of an
explosion and if you look at the
explosion it looks like quantum energy
this looks like some sort of quantum
blast so this may be how she gets her
powers by being exposed to quantum
energy much like Ava / ghost did in
ant-man and the wasp she got her powers
from quantum energy so maybe during this
quantum explosion her DNA gets fused
with a crease so it shows Carol Danvers
laying on the ground from a plane wreck
she has her Air Force uniform on and a
net benning's character explains that
they found her with no memory and they
made her into one of us what she's
saying is they made her into a Kree so
she could live longer stronger and
superior so this is probably partially
alive yes they found her after some sort
of plane wreck and explosion but her
memory probably wasn't completely erased
her head was probably a little bit fuzzy
from the wreck but what most likely
happened is they took her and completely
wiped her memory away because we see her
in this weird machine upside down was
sort of energy going into her head
and that could be them wiping away her
memory you were reborn so then it shows
some flashbacks of the past and Carol
Danvers says she keeps having these
memories and then she says that she
thinks that something in her past is the
key to all of this again implying that
the Cree actually wiped away her memory
we know from the comics that the Cree
aren't exactly good they're not these
noble warrior heroes that she talks
about they tried to invade earth in the
comics but if they wiped her memory of
course they told her we're these noble
hero warriors but that's not the case
which is most likely how she ends up
with fury so at some point in time
during the movie she'll probably find
out that she's from Earth the Kree are
going to try and invade and that's how
she becomes an ally to earth we then
have this scene with Carol Danvers and
Nick Fury in a quinn jet see that's a
yes-or-no question yes he asked her if
she knows how to fly it and she does and
that's because before the Kree got ahold
of her in her past life she was an Air
Force pilot we then get an awesome shot
of Captain Marvel taking off her Mohawk
helmet and if you noticed her helmet
comes off the same way that star Lords
helmet comes off which is really cool
mr. lorn can you get your folks to
Circle up mr. Lord star-lord is fine we
then cut to this next scene in which we
hear a voice saying would you like to
know who you really are this voice
sounds like Jude Law's voice and we have
recently found out that his character is
actually not Marvel and he is actually
Yan rod jaan raghav course is a villain
he is a Kree radicalist he actually
sides with Ronan the accuser who will
also be in this movie
remember this is set in the 1990s way
before guardians of the galaxy so Ronan
the accuser isn't this crazy Kree
fanatic yet so it seems like we're going
to see his transition from just a
high-ranking Kree officer and to Ronan
the accuser that we know in guardians of
the galaxy during this film and since
yon rug is actually a commander for the
Kree as well it's likely that he's close
to running the accuser so will most
likely see these two teaming up in the
movie and again we see this explosion
that looks like quantum energy remember
that Captain Marvel is supposed
to have some sort of connection to the
quantum realm so maybe her getting her
powers through quantum energy is the way
that they connect her to the quantum
realm so it shows her after the crash
she's looking at her hands she sees the
green blood obviously super confused cuz
again she's born as a human raised on
earth after this explosion she probably
becomes part Cree and now she has green
blood so she's super confused and then
we see through the midst of this
explosion through all this fire and
debris a scroll walking towards her
it shows the scroll pointing its gun at
Carol Danvers what most likely happens
here is that some crease shows up and
saves her could very well be Jude Law's
character yon rock and this is most
likely where the Kree take her they
knock her out somehow wipe away her
memory when she wakes up she knows
nothing and then they train her to
basically be a weapon then they show
Carol Danvers with Nick Fury and we hear
Carol say I think I had a life here
implying that she believes that she once
lived on earth but can't remember so we
see Nick Fury take her somewhere and he
pulls out some classified files and
shows her that she actually used to be
an Air Force pilot here on earth we then
hear her say what aren't you telling me
this could be her talking to young Rob
he'd even shows him after she says it
she is most likely asking him this
because in this movie we will probably
see the Kree actually tried to invade
earth because after this scene we don't
see her wearing her green creased Star
Force uniform anymore we see her wearing
her red blue and gold Captain Marvel
uniform and as the trailer goes on if
you freeze-frame you can actually see
her attacking some Kree soldiers we then
hear somebody say this war is just the
beginning and they actually show Ronan
the accuser when she says that so again
we might possibly see the Kree try to
invade earth along with the scroll
trying to invade earth as well so the
Kree and the scroll are at war with one
another maybe because they're both
trying to claim earth and then we hear
Carol Danvers / Captain Marvel dropped
that awesome line when she says I'm not
gonna fight your war I'm gonna end it
we then see her go full super sand she
goes into her binary mode and goes crazy
she's flying through space destroying
scroll ships like they're nothing with
her energy blasts Mohawk helmet and all
in binary mode
energy powers are insane her energy
blasts in binary mode are as strong as a
nuclear explosion and you can tell by
the way she's just destroying ships this
is why she's going to be one of the
strongest heroes in the MCU this is why
Nick Fury calls her after the snap it's
crazy to see how strong she is
and then the trailer actually ends with
one of my favorite parts it ends with
Nick Fury petting a cat but not an
ordinary cat in the comics Captain
Marvel has a pet cat named chewy in the
movie they actually changed his name to
goose and you can see that on his collar
goose is not a normal cat he's actually
an alien species called a Fleur Caen and
in the comics rocket racoon from
guardians of the galaxy actually tries
to kill goose so I was really excited to
see goose in the movie so that's it for
the full Captain Marvel trailer
breakdown it was an amazing trailer it
gave us a lot more info about the movie
and I thought it was just fantastic
especially the final scenes of the
trailer that final scene of her flying
through space full binary mode
destroying all the ships was just
amazing it gets me so hyped to see the
movie when it comes out let me know what
your favorite part of the trailer was in
the comments down below and I'm still
doing my give away I'm giving away
copies of infinity war at the art of the
movie art book copies of Avengers
infinity war Deadpool 2 and ant-man and
the wasp on blu-ray and some special
edition posters all you have to do to
enter for your chance to win is
subscribe to my channel like this video
and comment down below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero I
won't be surprised if I see a lot of
Captain Marvel's in the comments section
today and don't forget to subscribe to
my channel so you can stay up to date on
everything relating to Captain Marvel
and Avengers 4 as always thank you all
so much for watching
Wolf Wolf
[Music]